Bill's once a man and a woman who had
long in vain wished for a child these
people had a little window at the back
of their house from which a splendid
garden could be seen which was full of
the most beautiful herbs and flowers it
was however surrounded by an extremely
high wall and no one ever dared to
venture into the garden because it
belonged to an enchantress named dame
gothel who had great power and was
dreaded by all one day the woman was
standing by this window and looking down
into the garden when she saw a bed that
was planted with the most beautiful
rampion Rapunzel it looks so fresh and
green that she began to longed for it
and had the greatest desire to eat some
this design increased everyday and as
she knew that she would not get any of
it she quietly pined away looking pale
and miserable then her husband became
alarmed and asked what ails you my dear
wife ah she replied if I can't get some
of the rampion which is in the garden
behind our house then I shall die the
man who loved her thought sooner let
your wife die then bring her some
rampion yourself let it cost what it
will in the twilight of the evening he
clambered down over the wall and into
the garden of the Enchantress and
hastily clutched a handful of rampion
and took it to his wife she had once
made a salad out of it and ate it with
much delight she however liked it so
much so very much that the next day she
longed for three times as much as before
if the husband was to have any rest at
all he would have to once more descend
into the garden in the gloom of the
evening he let himself down once again
but when he clambered down the wall this
time he was terribly afraid for he saw
the Enchantress standing before him how
can you dare she said with an angry look
to descend into my garden and steal my
ramen like a thief you shall suffer for
it
the man panicked and quickly replied let
mercy take place of justice I only made
up my mind to do it out of necessity
my wife saw your rampion from the window
and felt such a longing that she would
have died if she had not got some to eat
The Enchantress allowed her anger to be
softened and said to him if the case be
as you say I will allow you to take away
as much a rampion as you desire
I only make one condition you must give
me the child which your wife will bring
into the world it shall be treated well
and I shall care for it like a mother
the man in his terror consented to
everything and when the woman gave birth
the enchantress appeared at once and
gave the child the name Rapunzel and
took it away with her
Rapunzel groans the most beautiful child
would beneath the Sun and when she was
twelve years old the intron tree shot
her into a tower which lay in a forest
and had neither stairs nor door but at
the top was a little window when the
entron trous wanted to go into the tower
she placed herself beneath the window
and cried rapunzel rapunzel let down
your hair to me Rapunzel had magnificent
long hair fine as spun gold and when she
heard the voice of the entron Taurus she
unfastened her braids wound them around
one of the hooks of the window above and
let her hair fall 20 ELLs down and the
Enchantress would climb up upon it after
a year or two it came to pass to the
king's son rode through the forest and
went by the tower he heard a song which
was so charming that he stood and
listened this of course was Rapunzel who
in her solitude passed the time by
letting her sweet voice for a sound the
King son wanted to climb up to her and
looked for the door of the tower but
none could be found
he then rode home but the singing had so
deeply touched his heart that every day
he went through the forest and listened
to it once when he was standing behind a
tree he saw an old woman come to the
tower and cry rapunzel rapunzel let down
your hair
then rapunzel let down her braids of
hair and the entrace has climbed up to
her if that is the ladder by which one
mounts I would have want to try my
fortune said he and the next day when it
began to grow dark he went to the tower
and cried rapunzel rapunzel let down
your hair immediately the hair fell down
and the king's son climbed up at first
rapunzel was terribly frightened when a
man such as her eyes had never yet
beheld came to her but the king's son
began to talk to her quite like a friend
he told her that his heart had been so
stirred that it left no rest and that he
had been forced to see her and then
Rapunzel lost her fear
and when he asked her if she would take
him as a husband and she saw he was
young and handsome
she thought he will love me more than
Dame Gothel does and she said yes and
laid her hand in his I will willingly go
away with you but I didn't know how to
get down bring me a skein of silk every
time that you come and I will weave a
ladder and when the ladder is ready I
will descend and you will take me on
your horse
they agreed that until this time came he
would come during the evening as the old
woman came by day the entron trips were
marked nothing of this until Rapunzel
once said to her tell me dame gothel how
it happens that you were so much heavier
for me to draw up than the king's son he
is with me hardly a minute you wicked
child cried the Enchantress I thought I
had separated you from all of the world
and yet you have deceived me in her
anger she clutched Rapunzel's beautiful
hair wrapped it twice around her left
hand seized the pair of scissors of the
right and snip snap the lovely braids
now lay on the ground and she was so
pitiless that she took Rapunzel into the
desert where she would have to live a
life of grief and misery on the same day
that she cast out Rapunzel The
Enchantress fastened the braids of the
hair which she had kept on to the hook
of the window and in evening when the
king's son came and cried rapunzel
rapunzel let down your hair she let the
hair down the king's son ascended but he
did not find his dearest Rapunzel above
but the Enchantress who gazed into him a
wicked and venomous look you would fetch
your dearest but the beautiful bird no
longer sits in the nest the cat has got
it and I will scratch out your eyes as
well rapunzel is lost to you and you
will never see her more the king's son
was beside himself with pain and in his
despair he left from the tower
he escaped with his life but the forms
in which he fell pierced his eyes then
he wandered quite blind around the
forest he ate nothing but roots and
berries and did nothing but lament and
wept over the loss of his dearest wife
thus he roamed about in misery for some
years and after some time he came to the
desert were Rapunzel with her two twins
that she had given birth to a boy and a
girl lived in wretchedness
he heard a voice and it seems so
familiar to him when he approached
Rapunzel knew him and embraced him and
wept two of her tears ran down his face
and into his eyes they began to grow
clearer and he could see with them just
as before he led her to his kingdom
where they were joyfully received and
they lived for a long time afterwards
happy and contented when I was a young
child my parents would often read fairy
tales to me now these fairy tales were
worded and told in a way that was deemed
suitable for children which clearly
differs to the themes and the way the
original Grimm fairy tales were told the
grim tales have very clear moral
messages and lessons behind them and
over the next few months we'll be
exploring some more of these tales and
hopefully you can see how over the years
some of these stories may have changed
the story of Rapunzel does have quite a
few morals that we can take away I've
seen some people claim that the story
warns against greed with the woman
craving the Rapunzel herb so much that
it eventually causes her to lose her
daughter but it's important to note that
the woman was pregnant and as we know
during pregnancy women do have weird
cravings so I wouldn't really consider
this a message against greed the story
does however teach children the
consequence of stealing the man of the
pregnant woman instead of asking the
Enchantress if he could have some
Rapunzel chose to steal it from her
garden and as a result it does
ultimately end up in the enchantress
been far less sympathetic towards him
and taken his daughter the story does
arguably also teach the value of
patience and determination
Rapunzel despite being locked away still
remains patient and optimistic and she
does eventually meet the king his son
but even at this point further patience
is required as they hatch a plan to
escape that would also take some time
when the king's son first hears Rapunzel
he attempts to climb the tower but he
sees there is no door and this task may
be impossible the prince refuses to give
up and continues to return every day and
he does eventually see how Dame Gothel
scales a tower showing us that if we
remain determined even the impossible is
achievable another message that seems to
be instead directed towards adults is
that children eventually grow up and
that is something they have to accept we
see Dame Gothel attempt to shelter
Rapunzel from the world look in her in a
tower but when she meets the prince she
feels that it's time to begin her own
life moving away from her mother rather
than taking the approach that Dame
Gothel does in punishing Rapunzel
attempting to live her own life parents
should accept that this is a natural
process and support their children for
those of you who have previously already
read or had the story of Rapunzel read
to you did you ever pick up on some of
these morals and lessons or war the
versions of the story you encountered
much different let me know in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology in fiction explained